oh god mike you're gonna okay i'm gonna
give you
as a matter of fact i'm gonna give you
the option because we're probably able
to get to one
through one of these today so uh we'll
get through we'll do the other one
either tomorrow but which one would you
rather do would you rather do
a a new episode of the fighter and the
kids
okay a clip of them or would you rather
do
a another pickup artist this guy's a
completely different pickup artist than
we've been covering before
i think i want to do fighter in the kids
i like a little shob in my life
all right all right he's really good man
him and his black friends that are
just have natural chemistry okay you
tell they hang out all the time
so this is them giving dating advice
here we go okay all right let's get into
these guys we're doing our iraqi waves
well we've done that before to be fair
yeah for like two seconds
yeah one word by the way one where we
were specifically making fun of a
person good point this is just hey let's
throw some wigs on
so man dr love go and read it britney
bro you funny as hell
no no go scroll down we don't need them
i want some dogs
here we go ah dick pic okay here we go
and dr love
i've been going through it i'm 33 years
old and me and my girl just split on new
year's eve after dating for six months
not long at all
uh she said she wanted to go into the
new year with a new slate good for her
she also went to san diego on a trip
with her chick friends on new year's
definitely got dick uh we never had any
arguments prior we thought she might
have been pregnant
ooh the week of christmas until she
finally got her period too much info
uh we were already playing on names for
the kid students
and with her living in l.a and me living
in arizona i was already contemplating
moving my entire life to l.a
if we got the news she was pregnant okay
but she's not i guess she wasn't loving
the man i was becoming
any advice i love this girl and can't
lose her
she's already going uh bye
to someone or someone on the chat now
who's this guy that jeremiah watkins
yeah that is jeremiah watkins who's that
he's the guy on um he's on kill tony and
he's actually pretty funny i actually
like jeremiah watkins he's funny he's
a complete [ __ ] dork and a complete
[ __ ] lib
but he's a pretty funny guy bye
bye felicia when he said she went on a
trip with her chick friends yeah
on new year's come on now the people
defending these uh guys you know so we
clipped the fighter in the kid thing and
we were making some
a little bit of racial humor as we do
and they were like oh
wait a way to make jokes just about to
race this is so played out
and somebody pointed out uh the black
guy with the band shirt was actually
raised by a white family and he knows
bands really well
so i'll have you know oh my god
like honestly dude i'd be more
embarrassed
knowing that you know what i mean i've
been i'd be more embarrassed knowing the
backstory
for the third mic of brendan schaub's
podcast
yeah you know what those girls she
wasn't pregnant before she pregnant
[Laughter]
is that what they do yeah on a night out
but um hey bro
man trust me yeah they grab their kids
look i got to tell you something man i
really gotta tell you something you
don't like the fighter and the noise
no i don't like the fighter in the crowd
or movie theater look i i
i'm gonna tell you this look we bus got
kalin's balls
and i get it
but this show needs brian callen to be
even marketable
it needed a brian i mean it's he
he's the only one that
could handle shop yeah he really was a
real talk
wrangler like he was very good at it and
to watch this like
look brian callan could be funny like
brian callan can be funny yeah he can
you know never you can't say that he's
because brian cowan could absolutely be
funny
i've been watching a show people going
to [ __ ] who the jew stuff whatever
but i watched a show called the
goldbergs with jeff garland in and it's
actually pretty funny and brian collins
in a couple episodes and he's actually
pretty funny in the show i'll admit that
but watching shaub because when it was
shobby when it was counted even though
shaw's the ufc fighter calen was the
alpha of of the podcasting thing right
in terms of that he would pull pull shaw
back in
he would kind of stop him from being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the time and make fun
of him
sharp's now the alpha male in this and
he can't do it he he can't
handle the ring leader and you're not
yeah he's not a good ring leader
yeah well cat don't
brandon's like who if i was a [ __ ]
that's what i would
there's some out there that the honeys
and a-z look like jeremiah let's just
get it out the way
now you should move to l.a okay and no
no
chill in arizona what's his word arizona
dude if you're live
entertainment why
also have these guys ever done a show
before like what is this they all talk
over each other like what's happening
yeah well you don't like having seven
people yelling
no i really don't it's it's like
watching one of those what was that
[ __ ] sports show where all the
talking heads are yellow each other jay
moore would host it sometimes
the jim rohn show jim rome yes jim rome
show yeah yeah yeah
by the way speaking of jaymore i
actually saw uh
do you remember that show dinner for
five or whatever
it's like john favreau did it yes yes
yes yes yes [ __ ]
obnoxious actor sitting around talking
about the craft and stuff
but like um i was watching one that had
him
obviously the whole cast of people we
love it was him
it was uh michael rappaport jaymore
but then it also had david milch and
timothy oliphant
all in this one and it's one of the best
ones to watch it's on youtube
timothy oliphant i've it's finally the
first time i've ever seen him
like sort of lose the veneer of like
cool dude bro
he was getting visibly annoyed with
jaymore
because of his interrupting and he's
like talking [ __ ] his trash talk and all
that stuff and like
he literally calls him a dick like in
the middle of the thing and he's like
he's like what do you want you're a dick
like whatever and then like
it bothered him enough that he brought
it up again later and he's like
wait wait wait wait wait wait i'm sorry
who called who i'm i missed timothy
called james called james
okay he's like yeah well you're a dick
what do you want and then like
you could just tell minutes later he was
bothered by it and he was like this guy
over here is calling me a dick a minute
ago and like
then it goes back to the other guy's
talking but you can actually see off to
the side he's going
what do you want from like your [ __ ]
your dick sometimes like it was a very
weird little sidebar
it's very awkward i was like damn you
know you're a dick when even tim of the
olive one's like dude come on
oh yeah i found the episode i mean i'm
not i don't know the
i don't i don't have a timestamp or i'd
play it but
yeah it's not something planning you're
just it was it's something worth
watching i'm gonna watch it on your own
because it's very funny the way they had
a little tense moment i was like oh
[ __ ] it's not he's not paying tax in
arizona yeah he's living life in there
but his girl asu is out there i'm
telling him his girl's over it man don't
come here chasing a girl that doesn't
want yeah bro
all the women don't chase a girl who got
a train ride or just keep going like
this
again the thing with this is when we've
covered it before we've talked about it
last time we did this
at least with fighter and the kid
without the z when it was calendar was
like structuring it was easier to
pinpoint brandon chobs
but this is just a sea of stupidity you
know
three how
[Laughter]
i was with this girl for 30 years she
had a train ran
on her in front of me on christmas
why do doctor love brandon what are you
reading
bro i wish that was this is that same
thing too where they go like
the show will be fine we just have to
laugh really loudly
all the time at nothing yes and make a
lot of noise
i said this last time i watched this
this is what you do
like when when you're like yo i want
listen
i'm gonna go talk to that girl right at
the bar but do me a favor like
i need everyone to just like start
laughing like really hard like everyone
act like i'm this [ __ ] right now
just get give me that give me like two
minutes of like laughing and like oh
[ __ ] this guy and like make me like hype
me up and then i'm gonna walk over and
talk to this [ __ ]
so that she thinks i'm cool that they're
doing that approach but like
to broadcast where it's like just keep
everyone will think this is good if
we're all like
yo this guy's the man yo like it's like
but you see
we're watching you there's no it's like
watching a free stuff a freestyle
competition
you know but like am i just a freestyle
competition at like a mostly white high
school um
yeah been the hardest do you think he
looks like jay yeah i love people
wait wait what i think he looks like jay
let me see again not in that one
picture with the beanie on oh oh yeah
yeah is this them going through
instagram again yes
and i like how it's not even on the
screen
two producers two we have zero
i can see what you're saying here that's
a great ovo shirt though yeah
anyways it's not jay so yeah yeah yeah
well
hey look man find love bro i see yeah
good man stay in arizona find that love
man there's
not being a deal dude yeah yeah are they
still talking about this yes
yeah yeah i wouldn't even worry about a
girl in la you don't want l.a jeremy
yo y'all got so funny oh i was just
looking at brendan
i realized he looks like a disney
princess you look like merida from brave
this is a show is this what the woman is
this what this asian woman
interrupted it to say they look like a
disney princess
you're fired everyone in the center
you're fired
i was looking at something that's the
one with the pet uh chameleon
no that's rapunzel ah [ __ ]
[Music]
what are you talking about you look like
somebody with completely different color
hair and complexion
just a little a little more nothing
worse when that happens
i want to point out that this isn't like
i just popped into the middle of an
episode
this is a clip that they they wait this
is a clip
this is one of their highlight clips
this is a clip yeah
this is like they're best of and when
you clip something it's like oh this is
a really good ball
oh my god i really thought that you were
just no
no look look this is from their fighter
in the kid clip channel
wow uh what's she from
let my hair grow from brave yeah i've
never never seen that
it's pretty good yeah so which is the
one with the long hair
uh
that's rapunzel you [ __ ]
is he the stupidest person on the
internet he could be mark lane's smarter
than him
and i mean that legitimately yeah
because at least mark lane is in his
wheelhouse
you know what i mean are you saying that
brennan shop should probably do like
wrestling action figure fights
no he can't even do that he'd probably
be bad at that
rapunzel this one but what's that movie
it's not called rapunzel no it's called
hey mike that was what we call when
you're trying to be not wrong but you're
wrong
no but he called it rapunzel well yeah
repunzel because she's
oh it's real that's how the guy found
her where she was going re
outside the tower
tangled that's right that's what the
chameleons tangle was fire dangle's good
i like tangles yeah you don't have to
put your arm around me these people are
calling [ __ ] disney movies fire
bro that was a fire at you bro aladdin
was like fire dude
but yeah you put it back take your wig
off dog started looking like something
from the side you do also brendan we
noticed this last time
brendan starts trying to act a little
not like hardcore but a little more
street
he starts trying to act like off
what were you trying to say you wanted
his personality to match his iq
yes this one says hey dr love i'm in a
new relationship and feel real happy in
it although i catch myself being jealous
over small things
because i have difficult past
relationship i never bring it up to my
new lady but wondering if you have any
tips on how i can get over jealousy
i still want my insecurities to ruin a
happy relationship
you said so the other thing is is we
talked about it when he was with callun
was
brendan needs somebody to mimic like you
know when he's on rogan we point out how
he mimics rogan and when callany mimics
callan remember when um
what's his face from the soup was there
um joel mchale was there
and he mimics him like brennan doesn't
have anybody to mimic
he has he has nobody look up to him to
mimic so this is just
what he is on his own said it right
there brother
say you're not comfortable with yourself
learn who you are as a person again
love yourself first let a man you're
becoming look at your mind he's like
this guy's seriously yeah i'm so serious
seriously i'm so don't don't distract me
i'm on a roll
listen his girl is going to find him
watch us like this is the [ __ ]
this is these are the guys you listen to
i'm gonna help you out here women if any
if any men watched us and the girl
catches them you should break up with
them immediately
okay well who's this uh therapist his
name's dr love
let's see let's see this is the best of
clip
i'm i really i didn't even believe that
when you said it i'm like
i thought you just pulled an episode up
and i'm like
who would clip who would go like this
needs to get out there people need to
see
how good the show is
no more don't disguise any part of yours
i love the transition that you're trying
to make in your life she's all babies
listen to four days
also you noticing
like this clip channel used to be huge
that's i mean it hasn't it's a hundred
times nine days ago
nine days ago there's a hundred thousand
subscribers but this this clip only has
1500 views 47 uploads and six down votes
for for a show that was big
those are women
those are not women i just realized this
is the worst episode of the view ever
he's is he done
i i don't know i mean he's he's in like
i would say this
if i'm brendan job right i'm worried
i'm panicking right now he thinks do you
think he's do you think he's smart
enough to panic
like i don't think he like i don't think
brandon shop
got money like he's fine as far as
making money goes but like
i would be worried about like okay is
this it am i not relevant anymore is
this my life now
him dumping callan was clearly a
business decision right
like you know the people that run the
show whatever whoever it is
yeah they didn't want to lose their
[ __ ] sponsors and [ __ ] and you had to
dump the
the guy who did by the way who did
nothing
but yeah brian callan as much as we made
fun of him brian callan did nothing and
he doesn't like us brian kellen does not
like us he specifically talked about
this
but brian callan didn't do anything that
thing is [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm calling around that's [ __ ]
garbage what they're trying to throw on
him is
is this 2001 sex regret [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] trash
whether you like callum or not i'm not
saying he hasn't done anything but i'm
saying that specific story is [ __ ]
stupid but whether you like calendar
don't like kellen
you push them out but you know what's
going to happen you're going to lose
your sponsors
anyway because who's going to
[Music]
pay to be on this show this this isn't
the same
show this is something completely
different
and terrible
we will give you love advice we'll let
you know what's going on with your mans
and you're blind
one on there yeah that's you this the
fighter and the talk
this is i don't know the i forget don't
they switch them out
mm-hmm oh no you don't it's like it's
like there's a redhead then there's uh
barbara they got barbara on there barbro
barbara walters
i'm done i'm done i'm sorry i can't
we watch a lot of stuff that we goof on
and we make fun of but this is a mess
this is just a meh it's not even fun
like when we would make fun of fighter
and the kid because you know it was two
guys and
and you know and brandon you know
calendar kind of set brandon up to look
like a [ __ ] reed
there were shoes on the table but this
is just
babbling nonsense i'd rather listen to
kills
[ __ ] killstein's poem again to be
honest with you ooh can we
no okay we're not also we're also not
doing that man r.i.p dude r.i.p divider
and the kid this is really bad
what are the comments on this i i can't
imagine they're great all right let's
get into these guys
wait so did they dress like this like
the whole thing i i don't know if they
dressed the whole episode this is just a
clip
the full episode's here i'll tell you
this is the full what's up kid welcome
no no they didn't they started to wear
the wigs
and oh wait hold on i don't know they
took it it's a live read so they did
take it off part way through the show so
i'm really sad i like that you're just
depressed no man because it's not even
on a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no it's funny to me but the way you're
just like usually you're like hey
we're gonna get these guys and today
you're like
you know so i don't even want to do this
i just feel
sad like what's happening what was that